and where is dr. pouchy I don't know but
every time you ask that question
whenever he's not here you look you say
where is he and you'll say is there a
problem no problem whatsoever every time
he's not here sometimes I'll ask him to
come because that's the first question
that you and a couple of others from the
fake news establishment ask is where's
dr. fat chief we're doing great together
yeah we're covering a different subject
today go ahead go ahead yeah president
you have said nobody could have seen
this pandemic coming but in fact
secretary a czar at a bio defense summit
in April 20 1999 flu of course I think
everyone in this room probably shares
that concern your own Health and Human
Services Secretary was aware that this
had the potential of being a very big
problem around the world a pandemic of
this nature who dropped the ball well I
always knew that pandemics are one of
the worst things could happen there's
been nothing like this since probably
1917 that was the big one in Europe it
started actually here and went to Europe
probably I've heard about she has made
wait a minute let me finish
I've heard about this for a long time
pandemics you don't want pandemics and I
don't think he was talking about a
specific pandemic he was talking about
the threat of a pandemic could happen
and it could happen most people thought
it wouldn't and most people didn't
understand the severity of it this is a
very severe what's happened is very
severe but I'd let you answer that I
assume that he was talking about the
concept of a pandemic Thank You mr.
president accurate absolutely for 15
years now this country is at a massive
effort at the federal state and local
level of preparedness for pandemic now
that largely has been as I said in those
remarks about pandemic flu preparedness
we knew about SARS we knew about MERS
which were earlier modifications or
variants of the corona virus none of
those achieved anything like what we're
seeing today but that's why for
successive presidencies including the
leadership of President Trump
there has been a great focus on pandemic
preparedness in fact it was just in
November I believe that the President
signed the pandemic flu preparedness
executive order that we have--we've and
we have also updated the pandemic crisis
action plan which has been the playbook
from which we've been working the
pandemic flu plan the again the action
plan from which we have been working
that coordinates the whole-of-government
whole of economy approach here so we've
all been very focused on pandemic
preparedness that's what we do but this
particular strain of pandemic who would
who would have known this particular
strain the secretaries are if you were
preparing for a pandemic at this
government we're preparing for a
pandemic why is it we don't have enough
masks
why is it we don't have enough medical
equipment and this administration's gave
us very little ammunition for the
military and very little shelf spend let
me just tell you you know it you know
the answer the previous administration
the shelves were empty the shelves were
empty so what you should do is speak to
the people from the previous
administration Jim and ask him that
question because the shelves were at the
ANU house the military shelves were also
empty we had no ammunition literally
that was said by one of your favorite
generals we have a sir we have no
ammunition guess what we had very little
medical supply also